direction vinnytsia maintenant c'est
dans le centre de l'ukraine le quartier
général de l'armée de l'air y est
établie l'aéroport local a été frappé
par des missiles russes il ya quelques
jours elle a encore un seul mot d'ordre
tenir bon coûte que coûte les précisions
nos envoyés spéciaux tarek avec lux
ragots
les travaux de déblaiement se
poursuivent ici à venitia après
l'attaqué qui a visé l'aéroport de la
ville les dégâts sont encore visibles à
l'oeil nu oui missiles de type h sans
aarhus ont complètement détruit cet
aéroport en faisant dix morts parmi les
civils et les militaires
des missiles tirés par des navires de
guerre qui se trouve en mer noire
bien sûr que nous avons subi des pertes
nos pilotes sont des héros et nos
défenses antiaériennes ont abattu des
avions et des missiles de croisière
technologiquement nous sommes derrière
l'ennemi ils ont des systèmes plus
moderne mais l'armée de l'air
ukrainienne s'est préparée et s'est
entraîné au cours des huit dernières
années nous avons formé notre personnel
pour affronter la grèce
l'ukraine et le bouclier de l'europe
nous sommes pour l'europe nous voulons
être européen il prouve ont déjà par
notre sang et notre courage
soyez stx tient
pas un grand nombre d'experts celui qui
maîtrise le ciel gagne la guerre d'où
ces appels répétés de la part de
l'ukraine pour que lui soit livré des
missiles et des systèmes antiaériens
capable de contrer l'avancée russe et
d'éviter le genre d' attaque comme celui
qui a eu lieu ici même à l'aéroport de
vinnytsia